[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari and as a
continuation of my series where i write
these pocket pieces i wrote something
influenced by the funk genre this week
thank you to paul for suggesting this
idea as a classical musician i wasn't
exposed to funk music until very
recently so first i had to spend some
time deliberately listening to some
recordings
here are a few things i took a mental
note of
[Music]
there is a very strong emphasis on the
downbeat
the overall subdivision of the pulse is
made up of even sets of notes instead of
odd
often times a short pattern made up of
an odd number of notes is repeated and
scattered over this pulse
and lastly the harmonic direction
generally seems to want to sit
comfortably in its place without moving
in too many directions
i tried to keep all of these things in
mind for my piece but i wasn't so strict
about keeping a steady pulse a form and
was only able to try to imitate the sort
of attitude that leads to an authentic
groove
before we move on here are some
additional remarks first of all last
minute i decided not to go with the
clavinet sound but with the wurlitzer
sound with the
guppy effect the wah effect
and i did that because i'm not used to
the clavinet sound and i'm not used to
the way it feels and sounds and i was
having trouble hearing certain pitches
the way i wanted them to sound with the
clavinet sound i think it's just a skill
and a touch that i just haven't acquired
yet
the type of strokes that you need to do
to get that slap sound
i'm not familiar with and it was it was
just hard for me to do also sustained
notes
i didn't like how it sounded with the
clavinet i much preferred
the wurlitzer
and quite simply i just preferred the
wurlitzer sound for this one
also because i'm very inexperienced when
it comes to funk music and new to the
genre it's just a bit awkward for me to
improvise some bits
because i'm just unfamiliar with that
kind of style where you're prioritizing
rhythm and focused on the groove
and there's just this attitude that i'm
very unfamiliar with
so that was a challenge but also very
fun
because it was a learning experience and
in terms of filming it was very fun
because first of all i was at the park
with bobby and
i'm never at the park so it was a nice
experience
but it was pretty challenging because
of a few things
the first thing was a keyboard setup
because i should have brought something
to elevate my keyboard but because it
was
near the ground i ended up putting a
towel there but it was still low because
it was low
it was really hard to play
the second thing is that there were
quite a quite a few people that kept
walking by and asking me questions or
talking to me
which
happens pretty often when i do these
videos but
not as often as as today yeah yeah okay
now here's the other thing if you're
using a tripod also i was having some
battery issues with the keyboard today
usually i put in a fresh set of
batteries before i do something like
this but today i just
didn't
and the thing about the keyboard is that
you can't tell when the battery is low
the only signal it gives you is that
maybe five minutes before
it's done it'll start to glitch and that
was happening luckily i got in a few
more takes before the keyboard died but
that was a little bit of a concern
it was my fault i should have put in a
fresh set of batteries
and now here's the final piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi bobby
hello